سلاح فعال جدا ضد الدبابات تبلغ تكلفه
صواريخ جافلين المضاده للدروع وفقا
للميزانيه العسكريه الامريكيه
178 الف دولار امريكي ارسلت واشنطن نحو 10
الا منها الى اوكرانيا هي نوع واحد من
الاسلحه التي تندرج ضمن قائمه طويله من
المساعدات العسكريه المكلفه جدا والتي
ارسلتها واشنطن في المجمل وفقا لمجلس
العلا الخارجيه فان اكثر من 60% من
المساعدات الامريكيه والتي تزيد تكلفتها
عن 75 مليار دولار مخصصه للجيش الاوكراني
اما بالنسبه للباقي اربعه مليارات دولار
فقط قدمت للمساعدات الانسانيه و266 مليار
دولار خصصت للدعم الاقتصادي وبحسب بعض
وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه فان تلك
المساعدات على سبيل المثال تدفع ايضا
رواتب 57 الف جندي متطوع مساعدات امريكيه
غير مسبوقه وكما لاحظ مجلس العلاقات
الخارجيه فانها تفوق بكثير المساعدات
المقدمه لدول اخرى مثل اسرائيل والاردن
وفق الكونغرس على 113 مليار دولار من
المساعدات تدفع على اربع دفعات اكثر من
اللازم بالنسبه لبعض الجمهوريين اليمنيين
المتشددين لكن بالنسبه للاخرين فان مثل
هذه الاموال ضروريه جدا لمكافحه المد
الروسي